natürlich hat man geträumt von der
medaille aber nie gedacht dass es
einfach zu erkennen kann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen zum sport in dem
sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers heute im sportbad die
frischgebackene olympia
silbermedaillengewinnerin im rodeln
korporal madeline ekel herzlich
willkommen und gratuliere dir auch
gleich hier zu beginn wahnsinn ist jetzt
23 hat den peking eine zweite olympia
medaille gemacht die silbermedaille in
der team staffel und das mit so jungen
jahren wie geht es dir jetzt nachdem sie
diesen erfolg noch zusätzlich fahren
konnte also folgt dass sie immer mit
allem das bildchen man habe kennen eben
in der team-staffel und ja also das wort
nimmt die medaille schon grün ich hoffe
es geht so weiter das ist ja gut wenn du
so weitermachst kommen einige auf jeden
fall für dich zusammen wie erleichtert
bist du dass du jetzt auch schon zurück
bist aus kinder die ganze situation vor
den spielen und in werften spielen und
natürlich sicher für euch hat lädt
innovativen eine zusätzliche belastung
ich froh ist man dass man dann wieder
daheim ist ja sie sechs ukraine hat es
wirklich sehr gut organisiert und die
waren wirklich mega freundlich muss man
echt sagen aber man ist froh dass man
mich weil ist eine chronische belasten
wolle statt einfach nicht in china
bleiben und
also einfach selber man wird einfach nie
ein positiver test haben weil man halt
einfach jahrelang für den wettkampf
trainiert hat und positiv erreicht hat
das einfach so schnell zunächst den
machen können das hat bei dir gott sei
dank gut funktioniert du hast deine
rennen absolvieren können schauen wir
noch kurz nach china selbst im
einzelbewerb war der start nicht so wie
erwartet was nach dem ersten lauf am 17
platz glaube ich aber dann eine
unglaubliche aufholjagd gestartet und im
endeffekt noch vierter geworden was
überwiegt da wenn du jetzt eine
retrospektive zu rückstaus er
das bittere gefühl dass es am anfang
nicht ganz geklappt hat oder die tolle
leistung und das zum vierten platz dann
doch gekommen ist ja es ist so nach dem
ersten nach forst meiner schon dass ich
bin ja kippt umgekippt und da ist das
rennen vorbei sie hat mir zu wieder
aufgeflammt auf die rodel damit eben
nicht ganz so viel zeit vor man geht
aber man was ist denn eigentlich schon
dass die zeit eigentlich vorbei ist und
dass die medaille einfach sehr schwierig
werde von dem her was ja ganz gut dass
sie nur drei läufe kraft obwohl mir eben
stetig verbessern habe keinen und
schlussendlich wird dann der vierte
platz gut als ihr glaubt wenn man vier
gute lauf griff hat und dann vierter
wird dann ist das sehr schade aber ist
somit den anfang ist dann eigentlich
sehr gut zeigen bis zum ende das heißt
du bist jetzt nicht auf den vierten
platz zurück und sagt na super vierter
bei olympia ich weiß ja wie das ist aber
videos schon angesprochen hast also und
man muss dann immer den kontext
natürlich auch mit bewährten auch in
eigenen analyse oder genau das würde auf
jeden fall so sehe ich also wie gesagt
wenn man ganz knapp vierter wert mit
drei oder vier super läuft dann ist halt
echt bitter weiß so ist der vierte platz
der gewonnen der vierte platz eigentlich
das heißt eine positive einstellung auch
zu dem ergebnis und dann kam die team
staffel lange haben alle natürlich noch
gehofft dass es auch gold noch erwerben
kann was war für dich die zweite staffel
medaillen nach abgang damals bei uns
jetzt eben silber wie geht es einem wenn
man da mit fiebert natürlich auch mit
den kollegen im team wenn man weiß dass
das nicht alles nur in deiner hand liegt
wie immer wenn du im einzelbewerb models
wie geht man damit um ja sie muss sagen
ich war sehr nervös weil er einfach kost
aber mit alles drin wenn wir da alles
super runter treffen und das war dann
schon ein ganz anderes gefühl weil eben
so bin ich nicht nur für mich
verantwortlich sondern auch für meine
teamkollegen machte eine art sorgen dass
er gute leistung bringen kann vor allem
musik hat einfach gerade in peking am
start sieht rot oder grün ist und will
sich natürlich andere motivation also
wenn der wolf erst die doppelsitzer
serienmäßig rot und zu bestreiten
konnten hinten blick zeigt dann sagt es
hat einfach also na was man einfach da
gibt es nichts mehr zu holen und dann
mal was ist grün reicht es eigentlich
motivierend dass da die anderen und an
einmal drauf was drauflegen wollen was
ist dann gewissheit war und und du deine
zweite medaille bejubeln konnte was hast
du da gefühlt die klassische sprach
journalisten der frage was fühlt man da
in dem moment ja ich muss ehrlich sagen
als sie habe nicht realisiert dass so
viel druck auf mir war dann einfach als
ökumenischer sie habe dann einfach mal
bei freunden tränen verdrücken können
einfach weil
es einfach mal hatte zur medaille und
sie sich einfach das große ziel ist aber
vor dass nicht nach olympia medaille zu
holen sondern eine schulische spiele
alles was zählt sind die medaillen und
deswegen war es dann schon nach brutaler
erleichterung dass man da jetzt mit
einer medaille heimfahren kann das ist
ein druck angesprochen du hast in den
weltcups durch deine sieger natürlich
auch druck vielleicht aufgebaut und sich
selbst in eine erwartungshaltung
gespielt hast du dich auch jetzt
favoritin auf die medaillenränge selber
gefühlt oder sowas gut ausblenden können
sie hatten einfach nicht das zu gefühlt
weil er gewusst es gibt so viele leute
die medaillen mitkämpfen können
und er ist das muss einfach jeder seine
leistung abrufen und durch ist an
bewusst beim salat schon ab ruft das
medaille möglich aber es dass es nicht
einfach wird fühlt man da auch
irgendeinen unterschied wenn man
zwischen einzelbewerb und der
team-staffel wechselt hat das einen
persönlichen andere bedeutung oder kann
man das gleich stimmt ja es ist ein
bisschen anders darüber was eben sofort
fürs team mal was man muss das abschlag
betreffen was nur durch viel passiert
sich dass es nicht treffen habe deswegen
es macht schon einen unterschied ja sie
ist auch dass mit abschlag tafel weil
das nicht angesprochen hast ist das was
man präsent hat wir haben den wettkampf
dass man weiß dass das ein zusätzlicher
faktor ist also klar man muss damit
rechnen dass man da abschlagen was man
muss jetzt vorbereitet
und wenn man die bahn durch geht muss
man eben nicht gleich auf rücken und
bremsen sondern warten bis das abstimmt
das muss dann der ist ja wenn das
vergleichen müsstest die karosserieteile
vor vier jahren und die silbermedaille
jetzt wie wir dass du den vergleich
einschätzen weil sie weiß dass ihr
damals halt wirklich die absolute
schwachstelle vom team war also dadurch
dass die einem mit olympiasieger und
sieben mit seinen gewinnen doppel was
man halt einfach war wenn man jetzt
selber und rief dann ist was möglich und
da war es damals im schwierig weil jetzt
die chance darauf ankommen wie viel
verliert die madeleine quasi
und diesmal war es schon so dass man
eigentlich schon eher auf in der stufe
gewesen seien alle und dass jemand
wusste immer leistung abruft dann kann
die muss nicht nur zeit quasi so wenig
zeit ein sind wir wirklich sondern kann
ich vielleicht ein bisserl was vorlegen
dh die ausgangssituation ist mental eine
ganz andere gewesen das war also damals
war schon irgendwie eben wie gesagt
möchte schwachstelle in welcher rolle
fühlst du dich wohler wenn du wieder
aufholen muss oder das eis oder wenn du
sagst ich kann sogar jetzt der faktor
sein der dann auch wirklich für positiv
entscheidend ist ja es ist schon cool
wenn man weiß dass noch mitfahren kann
und deswegen also ich glaub ich es
damals ja ganz gut gelöst die situation
aber es ist schon ganz gut wenn man weiß
dass man es eigentlich aus eigener kraft
schaffen kann jetzt bist du wahnsinnig
erfolgreich mit seinen jungen jahren im
rodelsport was was macht den erfolg aus
warum bist du so gut in dem was du tust
ja ich gute frage glaubt der kreml hat
einfach viele komponenten zusammen also
natürlich muss man einfach akribisch an
sich selber weiterarbeiten aber damit
die trainer und mit der
materialentwicklung also da haben wir
unser trainer schon extrem gut
gearbeitet und
das war super also wie gesagt ohne das
ganze team was dahinter steht was man
auf den stick funktioniert es sei nicht
so dass wir dazu sagen du dich
hervorheben also was sind deine großen
stärken die die auch beim rodeln
entgegenkommen was ich glaube bei mir
ist schon so dass sie sehr genau bin
also im märz hat irgendwie immer jedes
kleinste detail ausbessern und das hilft
nur wahrscheinlich armee eben immer
wieder weiter zu entwickeln was
natürlich an manchmal bislang steuern
für andere sein kann wenn ihr da immer
noch jeder kleinsten die 1000 schlimmer
fall aber ich glaube dass ich mach das
was mehr ausmacht das heißt eine
präzision und
seine genauigkeit ist etwas wo du sagen
würde dass hier hilft rodeln ist ja in
dem sinne durch die faktoren die damit
spielen beim wandern nicht wirklich ein
gesunder sport jedoch immer wieder von
seinem kollegen gesagt dass das halt vor
allem für nacken sehr belastend ist und
ist das etwas was du auch unser
schreiben würdest oder siehst du das
anders so hast du vielleicht andere
vorteile weil sie sagt vor allem für
mich war es der staat also der staat
einen vorteil weil ich bin halt doch
großen kölner verhältnisse ausnutzen wo
aber viele belastungen noch auf die
schulter also es ist schon so dass die
belastungen für den körper schon
teilweise zwar sein und hart sein und
vor allem auch durch die geschwindigkeit
kommen für mich unvorstellbar dass man
sich auseinander gesetzt und kann durch
den eiskanal jagt bei den
geschwindigkeiten ist das etwas was dir
gefällt oder ist das eher die
genauigkeit die präzision in den kurven
didier mehr liegt ja es ist schon das
auslaufen lassen und einfach veranlassen
nicht einer stunde schloss kronberg das
eigentlich ein speed mit nehmt also vor
dem herr klappt früher war ich schon um
einiges genauer noch was das angeht dass
sie wirklich millimeter arbeiten fahren
wollt und mittlerweile ist aber schon so
dass mehr laufen lassen was eine
kalkulation wassern eigentlich
prinzipiell schneller macht ist das auch
etwas was dann immer noch dieses jahr in
allen kik bringt oder
drauf so was gar nicht versuchst du das
auch gar nicht ja schon also ich glaub
so ganz natürlichen adrenalin rodeln das
geht einfach gar nichts die nachbarn
harder unterschiedlich was man halt man
muss jetzt einfach voll konzentriert
sein weil sonst keinen halt doch fehler
passieren und da unfälle passieren
deswegen ist bislang unklar wie das
gehört einfach dazu ist das auch etwas
wo du dass deine freizeit oder im alltag
auch so
suchst oder oder ist das wirklich ganz
gezielt auf der rodelbahn fokussiert ja
es ist schon als ebenso jemand dass du
da bist läuft man den adrenalinkick
indem man einfach mal etwas sachen
ausprobieren macht zum beispiel eben
alles ziemlich felsklettern aber
probiert und es war schön aber winter
mit der höhe und das wars also am seil
hängt man kann trotzdem runterfallen und
dass ich dann schon also aber wenn man
seine berühmten hat dann fühlt man das
besser als ich finde manchmal challenges
angehen hat das ist auch bei euch schon
einmal das was passieren kann dass man
stürzt das man vielleicht gegen die bahn
kraft der fans mit wenn man weiß bei
welchen geschwindigkeiten man da sich
jetzt in den eiskanal setzt ja also
eigentlich nicht wirklich war rechnet
nicht damit dass man stürzt also man
merkt einfach probieren so gut wie
möglich zu umfahren und und ja also es
passiert natürlich immer wieder das noch
mal stürzt aber in die meisten fälle
geht es ja gut vielleicht glimpflich aus
also im verhalten ist für unser
schiedsrichter passiert eine recht wenig
aber natürlich also gerade zu fallen
oder so erwähnt da war es mal ein
fachmann sollte zeit einfach nicht
verletzen aber trotzdem muss man
folgendes kamera vorne dabei sein will
es geht ja um medaillen es geht um punkt
es geht um quali das heißt man kann gar
nicht mit angezogener handbremse fahren
obwohl man wahrscheinlich eben
vorsichtiger sein sollte oder eben
unterbewusstsein sich natürlich wünscht
dass man sich nicht verletzt auch das
ein spannender aspekt jetzt kann man
deine familie ja schon ein bisschen als
roma familie bezeichnen oder seiner
großtante war schon selber rodlerin
seine jüngere schwester fährt auch warum
legt euch das rot und seiner familie
alles muss mit meiner großtante habe
eigentlich erst dann mit 15 16 jahren da
fragt also das habe während meiner
anfangsphase in
nikosia ich weiß nicht warum es uns als
eines quasi liegt oder aber
ich glaube was wir gerade kleine
schwester hat sehr viel potenzial das
sie danach eben jetzt diesen weltcup ihm
also fix ins weltcup-team und ja keine
ahnung wieso wie würdest du das
verhältnis zu deiner schwester
beschreiben das haben wir wieder
schwierig wenn athleten und athletinnen
geschwister gemeinsam vor allem die
gleiche sportart machen das ja auch mal
wieder zu komplexen situationen kommen
ist das bei euch alles easy oder kommt
es immerwieder dann auch zu
streitigkeiten oder und
meinungsverschiedenheiten oder dass man
sich nicht einig ist über bestimmte
dinge wie sieht es bei euch aus ich
glaube also wir sind relativ weit
auseinander mit fünf ja da manchmal ein
bisschen unterschied dass man nicht so
viel miteinander gemacht hat aber
natürlich also meine schwester ich
einfach sportlich aktiv und sich bunt
und dann auf einmal wieder an dass sie
eben ans werk gehen wir zu lassen oder
es macht mir das jetzt machen wir das
also da ist schon brutal grad in lluc
dann haben wir eben viel gemeinsam immer
gemacht und trainiert und ja wie gesagt
dass sie glaubt dass sie wirklich
potenzial leben hat und
ja das muss funktionieren machen also
dass es funktionieren kann das muss
prinz border gegenseitig weiterbringen
gibt es etwas das du ihr mit geben
kannst oder mitgeben möchtest oder bist
du da eher vorsichtig weil du mir nicht
zu viel rein reden möchte also gebe ich
immer wieder tipps aber natürlich hat
seinen eigenen kopf und bringt es
dasselbe
durch deswegen ja sein extra sie sagt
schon immer wieder sachen was sich dann
selber schlussendlich mitnehmen das ist
ja entscheidung jetzt bist du zweifache
olympia medaillengewinnerin
glaubst du dass das vielleicht auch für
sie ein zusätzlicher druck ist dass sie
da auch ihr nachfolgen muss oder denkst
du dass ich das gut ausblenden können
ich glaube für sie ist eine recht
motivieren also was ist so weit mit
krieg hatte also sie sieht das als
motivation das ist halt irgendwie
schaffen macht und in die nächsten vier
jahre dann eben ab und wer dabei sein
möchte als ihr glaubt nicht dass es viel
mehr druck sondern eher die motivation
im vordergrund steht die figur zu seinen
anfängen wie ist es bei dir dazu
gekommen dass du dich auf die robe
gesetzt und dann den eiskanal hinunter
geklettert ist so wie mir ist einfach
ganz leicht passiert doch die
volksschule eben da war die welt muss
den eagles 2007 und eigentlich wollte
freundin von mir anfangen und ewald sei
okay problem ist halt einfach und er ist
es einfach bin halt dann dabei bleiben
und sehr alt lassen aber eben eine
chance mehr noch sie dass sie es
angefangen habe war das dann so dass du
immer dann schon wusstest ich werde
profi ich werde
olympia-medaillengewinnerin und hat sich
das erst über die jahre dann ergeben
also eben ins büro gegangen und dann
wird man sich dann eigentlich für die
schule entschieden hat war es dann
eigentlich so weit dass texaco okay
jetzt war es meine dass man den
leitungsweg wirklich ein schlag bis
dahin war es mehr eine viel mehr spaß
bezogen und quasi mit freunden einfach
reisen
und ja aber eben sobald man sich eher
für die schule eben mit knapp 14 ist man
da entschieden hat da war es mir dann
schon wo man eigentlich eher etwas
verrichtung nachgehen will das heißt der
weg ist dann fast schon vorgezeichnet
dass man weltcup und dann olympia fährt
hat dass du einen moment wo du gesagt
dass
jetzt weiß ich ich möchte unbedingt bei
olympia am podium stehen gab es das bei
dir oder hat sich das erst entwickelt
also für mich war es schon so dass sie
also natürlich richtig vor jedem das
ziel olympia medaille als bürger
sportler wenn man es nicht sagen würde
aber für mich war 2018 war sein so dass
sie gewusst habe
wer richtig schwierig eigentlich grad im
norden
und da war ich einfach nur bei weitem
nicht so weit deswegen war ein natürlich
hab mal geträumt von der medaille aber
nie gedacht dass es einfach zu erkennen
kann
man muss sich ja in eurosport hat auch
relativ früh entscheiden ob man
im einzel bleibt darüber denn den
doppelsitzer geht war das für dich
jemals ein thema das damendoppel
eigentlich weltcup aufgenommen wird war
das für mich noch nie ein thema weil es
nicht geben hat das angebot und
natürlich als frau bei die herren mit
staat nicht korruption weil einfach
meiner musik oder einfach ganz anders
überlegen sein am start war und deswegen
war die entscheidung dann also insel
bleibt und ob man das wirklich
durchziehen macht so die doppelsitzer
entscheidung kann ich jetzt mit becker
olympia passiert der damen a dabei und
da weil es einfach die jugend
wahrscheinlich entscheiden dürfen aber
für dich wenn du im einzel schon so
viele jahre jetzt natürlich bist ist das
wahrscheinlich keine option oder gar
nicht dass du das machen möchte sollte
sondern nur vom verständnis der sportart
der bewerber selbst also wenn man jetzt
jahrelang geben so gut war kann man da
nicht auf dem doppelsitzer einfach so
wechseln würde ich prinzipiell so sagen
endlich also gerade bei die herren ist
dazu also jetzt doppelsitzer anfangen
weil eigentlich fast schon zu spät wir
uns damals wäre es eventuell vielleicht
gar nicht so spät weiß auch das ja erst
alles aufbaut das heißt wenn man es
unbedingt wollen würde wird sogar gehen
also es wäre die möglichkeit dar aber
ich höre heraus dass das du fühlst dich
sehr wohl allein auf der roben was
glaubst du wird sich jetzt nach peking
für dich so verändern nach diesem tollen
erfolg ist nämlich eben nicht deine
erste medaille hat es schon immer etwas
das du weißt du was sich da alles so tut
wahrscheinlich auch welche medienrummel
nach olympischen spielen auf einen
entgegenkommt war das wirklich gutes du
da schon vorbereitet warst durch
südkurier sagt gerade durch krone ist
eigentlich gar nicht so viel und ja es
sind ein paar termine die man eigentlich
ganz gerne mitnimmt weil es ja eine
softair ich dass man sie machen darf
aber sonst also es ändert sich
eigentlich nicht wirklich viel am leben
bleibt gleich nach einer der termine ist
auch natürlich der empfang gewesen die
medaillenfeier die gemeinsam als team
erleben konnte österreich war wahnsinnig
volk reich bei diesen winterspielen hieß
es so intim gewesen die stimmung wie
hast du dich gefühlt teil dieser so
erfolgreichen mannschaft zu sein und
auch eben durch seine erfolge beitragen
zu können ja es ist ein tolles gefühl
dass man außerdem dass österreich heißt
doch sehr kleines land einfach so gut
mithalten kann
deswegen es sich kurz cool dass man
eigentlich ein beitrag dazu leisten kann
dass österreich das sportland ist und
das hat eigentlich das wichtige ist dass
er im spitzensport programme oder im
förderungen wie eben bundesheer oder für
polizei dass das eigentlich gibt also
weil ohne dass klar wird man mit nicht
um eine geschlechter aussagen weil die
kennt man ich betone es wunder seit
meinem fall mitmachen
2017 weil das jetzt angesprochen was
dann in ausbildungsdienst geleistet gibt
es irgendetwas was derzeit mitgenommen
dass das ein jahr vor den olympischen
spielen gegen das es so du sagst das
begleitet mich bis zum heutigen tag was
du gelernt hast sauberkeit ordnung ist
im leben solche sachen nicht dass du das
eigentlich gehabt hätte ist aber oder
sagst das hat mich wirklich
vorangebracht ja ich sag es war eine
ganz gut einfach sein der gruppe
eigentlich mal weil man hat halt doch
eben die fünf wochen wirklich in der
gruppe verbracht und ich glaube das hat
eine rasse bisschen zusammenhalt man hat
andere sportarten kennen gelernt den man
jetzt aber den bremer trifft haben
eigentlich keinen kleiner freundschaften
geschlossen du bist auch im stützpunkt
in innsbruck stationiert hat natürlich
auch die trainingsbedingungen vor ort
wie kann man sich den trainingsalltag so
vorstellen ja also im normalfall so
moment wenig betrieb noch ein bisschen
eingeschränkt durch corona normalerweise
eben montag immer die standes kontrolle
und da geht man mit einem sportanzug
meldet sich und dann kann man eigentlich
gleich mit dem training anfangen was
sobald ich natürlich weil man hat einen
ganzen trainingstag vor sich das ist
eigentlich echt tolle option dass man da
einfach dann wirklich vor ort an erklärt
trainieren gehen kann und
du bist wie ich schon erwähnt aber noch
sehr jung wenn du in diesem fall schon
so erfolgreich ist
wie schafft man es dann sich weiter zu
motivieren sich neue ziele zu setzen
tust du dir sehr leicht oder brauchst du
eine ungewisse phase nach so einem
höhepunkt um die neue ziele zu suchen
vielleicht neu zu formulieren wie wie
gehst du sowas an ja ich muss sagen bis
jetzt nur bis peking weil einfach der
ganze fokus darauf an die ganze energie
dahin gegangen sein jetzt machte mir
einfach entspannen ein bisschen
runterkommen davon und danach geht es
wieder los mit training und neue ziele
zu setzen und bei mir gibt es schon noch
einige ziele noch erreichen kann und dem
ansetzen kann also soweit ist noch nicht
das ist alles vorbei deswegen sagt doch
einiges aus auf jeden fall und einige
jahre die hast du noch erfolgreich fort
was stellst du dir in einem
anderen leben noch so viel hast du
natürlich den gesamten fokus voll auf
peking gehabt was gibt es für dinge die
du noch erreichen möchte das vielleicht
auch beruflich nach deinem sport wenn du
dann irgendwann einmal ganz ganz später
auf mich aufpasst gibt es jetzt schon
klare pläne oder lässt du das alles auf
sich zukommen also noch ganz klare pläne
haben ethische die nebenbei ein bisschen
aber ich war es nicht ganz genau was ich
hab nur zeit dass jemand die richtung
genau auswählen wo ihr dann genau
hinsehen will deswegen ja ich hab eben
noch ein bisschen zeit mit darauf zu
orientieren was machst jetzt zum
entspannen kommt dann langer urlaub auf
dich zu oder bis dann sofort schon
wieder in der vorbereitung für die
nächste saison da sie es war lange
urlaub werni mache dutzend städte trip
und dann gehts eine resche wieder weiter
und
suchte ich jetzt einfach ein paar
freunde sehen weil deshalb zu kurz kamen
ist dass man da mal wieder bisschen
austausch hat einfach zu reden und
wieder in kontakt mehr aufbauen was
steht in der nächsten saison bevor für
dich als nächstes die nächste
weltmeisterschaft wieder und das wird
sicher wieder so ein höhepunkt sein und
natürlich einfach da weiter machen wo
jetzt eine aufgehört habe das heißt es
fehlt dir nicht an dingen die danach
erreichen kannst du wünschen sich
natürlich dafür viel erfolg und
gratulieren auch noch mal ganz herzlich
zu diesen tollen leistungen vor allem
unter den schwierigen bedingungen und
voraussetzungen und vor ort eine
wahnsinnige mentale performance dass du
da noch im einzel gezeigt hast was in
dir steckt also dazu die situation noch
einmal ja das war es beim sport bot mit
marin egal danke dass ihr mit dabei war
bis zum nächsten mal
[Applaus]